let's see let's talk to our caller from
the eight-six 0 area code who's calling
today from eight-six
Oh ahead David can you hear me yes I can
who's this this is Chris calling from
Savannah Georgia and my question is last
week
Trump's approval rating kind of
skyrocketed yeah it's over 55% I believe
do you think that this will really hold
I know that like during crises the
president's approval rating kind of goes
up because people kind of rally behind
him but since you know coronavirus is
just the first thing that we have to
worry about then the recession and stuff
do you see it necessarily holding and
how will that affect the election do you
believe so a couple things number one
yes Trump's approval rating is up and
his handling his marks as he likes to
call them on coronavirus are also pretty
high and so part of it is and people
tend to rally around the president in a
crisis even if they're doing a pretty
bad job as I believe Donald Trump is I
think the other aspect of this as you're
talking about is that not everybody is
yet feeling you know when you think
about 40 percent or 35 percent of the
cases are in New York Lots large swathes
of the country still have very few cases
that they know about there are probably
a lot of people who are saying hey
things are okay here
Trump's doing a good job and of course
that is a lot of people who simply
aren't aware of the real case number
because we're not fully testing yet
however you bring up a good point which
is as the unemployment numbers go up and
as this extends if indeed it does you
may see that level off or go the other
way but my prediction if you say to me
David you've got a bet right now
coronavirus helps or hurts Trump in
November I bet that it helps even if he
continues to handle it poorly because
there's plausible deniability there's
always the idea that he could have
handled it worse and things would have
been even worse than they are and so I
if you say David you've got a place a
bet does this help or hurt Trump in
November I believe coronavirus helps
Trump in November okay yeah I guess they
kind of makes sense I
I think the the Trump's been doing not
not really the best job no trying to a
I'm back from college then my parents
are like getting mad and all the
journalists and reporters thinking that
they're asking dumb questions and stuff
and I just kind of got to put my head
down because there's a file on me but
it's just I don't know III I kind of
Wilbur grudgingly vote for Biden I guess
over Trump but I I'm just trying to get
the word out to people because I mean
George is kind of going purple so yep
we'll see what happens we will we will
and it'll really come down to who who
chooses to get out to vote and how bad
will the situation be you know what we
what we would unfortunately if the
Republicans are more likely to believe
that they shouldn't be staying home we
could end up with the unfortunate
situations that Republican turnout is
significantly higher than Democratic
turnout because Democrats are much more
likely to be staying at home we don't
know what things will be like in
November you know it's eight months away
what seven seven months away we'll wait
and see yeah that's very true well thank
you for taking my question David big fan
of the show and yes stay safe Thank You
likewise and I appreciate you calling in
today